all right so you worked with Bill Murray
on Broadway didn't you
oh no okay here's what happened
I did uh after
the World Trade Center World Trade
Center I did a play Bill Murray was
doing a play with Sigourney Weaver it
was it's more of a reading kind of play
but it was quite powerful it's called
the guys right and I got a call
um saying
um
because Susan's husband Jim he was a
theater guy and I got a call saying
um we'd like to come in and replace Bill
he's got to leave oh good
would you cover the replace bill and um
um I was like yeah sure and then Susan
Saron came in with me to replace
Sigourney
um I'm not sure so you're not sure
you're actually you never really you
never worked with them I've never read
my bill I would have loved to have but I
mean even now I know he's in trouble and
[__] but whatever yeah people are in
trouble
um people get in trouble for bad action
so people get in trouble I don't listen
here's the thing about
um reporting and hearsay
um I find it not to be particularly
reliable there's two sides of the story
I'm not ever saying
um if there are complaints from women
about being harassed I take that
seriously
I had heard that I've always heard it in
this kind of like affectionate
curmudgeny way that bill was a bit
grumpy
he's also one of my favorite movies of
all time
Lost in Translation oh yeah I love that
movie and I think his performance is
brilliant no doubting he's a brilliant
actor yeah but I had I had heard he was
a bit commodity and all that stuff for a
minute Richard Dreyfuss supposedly said
he was a monster and what about Bob a
monster I I I I don't
I don't
I've worked with Richard Richard a
monster no he's great no no he's the
most highly energetic enthusiastic actor
actor friendly guy I really enjoyed
working with him did you have you ever
worked with any and you know what to say
but just any [__] any guys like that
are big stars at your likes this son of
a [__] I'm just gonna do my part I'm
gonna do what I do and [__] him [__] her
whatever it is no no
no I replaced somebody who was an
[__] and I heard about it
what an [__] it was I'm not saying
who it was
um
but I have never worked with some one
that I've worked with some difficult
people
like I'm working with
at that time he had a reputation and I
will say because I love him Val Kilmer
right and I worked with Val and this is
a true story on the first day that I
made Val
he comes out and he's wearing he's got
like this pristine white t-shirt that
says uh
what was that movie you did with DeNiro
uh
heat hey it's got a beautiful white he
t-shirt he's got a cup of coffee
and I'm standing there talking to the
director and he comes up and I've got
like this kind of like I don't know like
nylon uh jacket or something on
and comes up he's got a cup of coffee he
puts his arm around me and starts
pouring the coffee down the front of my
jacket while I'm talking to the director
and I'll just look at it and I just get
it and I just wipe it all over his nice
white T-shirt
and that set up a good relationship
really yeah I didn't get upset I just
wiped the coffee back on his T-shirt and
and
I think a lot of people and he probably
would have even said he was I mean
touche having a pretty difficult time at
that time yeah and he there was some big
blow-ups on that set and but
me personally I didn't have a problem
with him that's awesome and and you know
he would come into my trailer and he
would say things to me like now listen
man I want you to
um see these spring he had all these big
rings on he's like I think that you
should wear it this ring
in this scene because it represents X Y
and Z and blah blah blah and now what I
know is the shot we're about to do
is the three of us standing on a hill in
silhouette against the Sun so I go give
me the room that's great
it made him happy